the u.s. is having a bit of a mini
crisis with Saudi Arabia right now Saudi
Arabia is one of our biggest allies in
the Gulf but they've been upset about
what we've been doing with Iran and
what's happening in Syria and just last
week the United States said we support
the universal rights of the Saudi
Arabian people and what we were alluding
to there was basically women's rights
because women cannot drive in Saudi
Arabia this is 2013 a couple years ago a
law was passed that eventually they'll
be allowed to drive and eventually
they'll be allowed to vote it's very
confusing but then John Kerry was
speaking last week and they're trying to
fix up this whole diplomatic kerfuffle
and here's what he said it's no secret
that in the United States of America we
embrace equality for everybody
regardless of gender race or any other
qualification but it's up to Saudi
Arabia to make its own decision about
its own social structure and choices and
timing okay I I basically am on board
that with the United States should not
be dictating to the world how they're
allowed to run their internal affairs
that seems to be why everybody hates us
but it does seem kind of weird to me
that in 2013 with a country that's
considered an ally of ours we're not
allowed to say to them maybe women
should just be equal like like women
having equality doesn't even seem like a
real issue to me should we have no
influence whatsoever in the country's
domestic of it I hope that we have
influence and I think we should have
influenced Minh if you look at the
global community and just look at it
videos that are going viral of women who
were risking themselves and they're
getting behind the wheel and people are
loving it even men dressing up as
winners are getting behind the wheel and
driving and people are wanting to watch
it but you know just recently somebody
was driving a woman was driving out of
Kuwait into Saudi Arabia with her
diabetic father that she was trying to
get to the hospital she was arrested she
was detained as she was crossing the
border even though she had a real
purpose to be behind the wheel of that
car you hope that things like that and
that if the global community and the
United States if we get in on that
dialogue you would hope that we would
have an impact and I think that we
should not just sit the fence but you
know with a lot of this this has an
economic impact and that's one of the
things they're they're they're hedging
their bets I guess they're watching out
because
we have an economic interest in Saudi
Arabia and I would imagine that that is
why this is so so you look at my turf so
I do with oil I actually I think you
were trying to say well what I think
should we have any influence she was
arrested that woman um no no that won't
not you better when it was arrested I
was the one driving she did not wave
when someone let her into a lane so
that's why so you driving technicality
well you should be arrested if you don't
wave and I let you in God there better
be a police car signal is given some
sort of thank you yeah I think that it
is obviously politically driven and
there is a part of me that as a chick
yeah contrary reason I know right
contrary to what people are saying i am
a trick but that yeah i'd like to see
women not have to wear the burka I know
I know ah but they can't drive in that
book have you seen some of them some of
them cover like they have a special veil
that covers their eyes like they
shouldn't be driving if their feet are
gonna get all caught up in the brake and
the gas then you know what news
elaborate there's a lot going on yeah
but I I get upset more about other
things than just the driving the driving
just seems like yes that you should be
able to get in your car or whatever a
vehicle anything and go if you want
freedom it's it's part of the freedom
but there are so many other issues right
that are more pressing that are
definitely where I don't think nothing
son of our business but we're never
gonna get anywhere you mean our own
domestic issues here for them and in
Saudi Arabia yeah so for just a house
you get without a man it who's a
relative can't talk to another dude or
else they're like hey hussy getting the
red light district you [ __ ] right baby
I asked him what time it was well they
just let them vote they think that your
or something yeah but they still can't
drive to the polls okay yeah so there
it's just such a serious and it can't go
without a little chaperone and II think
I've been able to vote who they want to
vote for were they gonna vote for who
daddy and husband and brothers say you
should vote for right so it's there's so
much more other than like I want a Ford
Focus like there's more on earth who you
guys are sponsored by yeah but I'm you
can see you know i don't i don't think
that that I feel like is the least of my
issues with women in
Saudi Arabia right do you guys think we
should have just sort of basic standards
if you're gonna be an ally the United
States you have to just have a basic
standard women should be treated equally
I mean simple things you shouldn't be
killing gay p but it's not my favorite a
lie no no of course it's a super but so
we can't conflate those do they know
it'd be ideal if we could do a surety
that I've hated say that if we would all
say hey you guys stop supporting Justin
Bieber's career you know the ideal to
say a lot of things but I don't think
that we get even close to being able to
tell them what to do because there are
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
religious years that are way stronger
than you know John Kerry and the United
States of America but the world has
gotten smaller though now because of the
internet so it becomes an issue that
everybody gets involved in rather than
just the people of Saudi Arabia so that
could put pressure on their culture
which I think it already has you see
changes but it's not happening quickly
enough I think for a lot of people
doesn't it social also show sort of just
our general hypocrisy about everything I
mean Iran which we're dealing with some
other stuff with related to the nukes
but women are allowed to drive their
women are allowed to drive in Syria so
we have countries that we keep pushing
as the enemy that treat their women
better than one of our biggest allies in
the region that's why I'm saying it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter we are
not going to be able to get along with
another country because they let their
chicks paint their toenails just I'm
saying it's not going to it's not going
to help anything in the longer they have
to as a society decide you know that
that is really inappropriate to not
allow a woman to talk to another man
like what is it what is it within you
guys as a society that makes you fear a
chick with opinions but basically yeah
show me on the doll where you were
touched you know I mean because
obviously you have a much larger problem
than just you know stick shift
you